ديجين وقد ذبت فيها الحياه من جديد بعد
اسابيع من الاغلاق الشامل ضاقت خلالها
حياه السكاني جر قيود مكافحه وباقي كورونا
السلطات الصينيه قررت اخيرا التخفيفه من
تلك القيود
بعد ان طاقه ذرعا كغيره من المواطنين
بطوابير اختبار الفيروس اليومي وجدت لهم
السلطات حلا يخفف عنهم معاناه الاصطفاف في
الجو البارد
اشترى للتو ادوات اختبار للفيروسي منزليه
بسيطه غدت متوفره في الصيدليات وتعتمدها
الجهات المسؤوله ما جعله اهل بيته يتنفسون
الصعدا ولو قليلا
اما الان وبعد رفع كثير من القيود وتسهيل
الاجراءات سنكون سعداء علينا جميعا ان
نبقى على وعين بخطوره الفيروس وان نلتزم
باعلى درجه الحيطه
الحكومه الصينيه اعتمدت سياسه التخفيف
التدريجي للقيود الصحيه في العاصمه دون
رفعها بالكامل
الا تزال المراكز التجاريه مغلقه امام
المتسوقين
والمطاعم لا تستقبل الزبائن
يجب علينا تنفيذ اجراءات الاستجابه مع
الحفاظ على بروتوكولات الوقايه والسيطره
على الفايروس وفيما يتعلق ببعض روابط
المخاطر المحتمله وطالما ان جميع المناطق
تطبق الاجراءات وبسلامه يمكننا تقليل
مخاطر تفشل الوباء
لكننا شوارع العاصمه بدت مزدحمه بالمركبات
ما يشير ربما الى حركه الاقتصاد من جديد
ليست العاصمه بيجين وحدها التي شملها
تخفيف قيود مكافحه الوباء بل عاد
المواطنون في مدن صينيه اخرى الى ممارسه
حياتهم بشكل شبه طبيعيا بعد اسابيع من
الاغلاق العامه في مدينه كوانجو حاضره
مقاطعه تكواندو بجنوب الصين استئن فتح
خدمات تناول الطعام وفتحت الاسواق امام
الناس وبدات محطات القطار والحافلات في
المدينه تقل المواطنين واكثر من 10,000
عامل
وموظفا علقوا فيها طيله فتره الاغلاق بعد
ان شهدت المدينه احتجاجات قبل ايام على
قيد قرونا ومثلها بيجين
ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره بيجين